翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Hiroko Kawano
「悩み」という言葉を聞いたら
皆さん どのようなことを思い出しますか？
おそらく多くの人たちにとって
「悩み」というものは
ネガティブなものではないでしょうか？
しかしこの「悩み」という言葉は僕にとって
とっても大切なものなんです
今日は僕の悩みについて
少し話させてください
おそらく 多くの人たちを悩ませてきた
質問って必ずありますよね？
僕は 小さい頃
「お母さんが好き？ お父さんが好き？」
「どっちかしか選べなかったら
どっちを選ぶ？」という質問が
実はウザイ質問ナンバーワンでした
（笑）
それぐらい僕を困らせました
でもそれ以上に
僕を困らせてきた質問があります
それはこれです
「あなたは何人なの？」
僕は23年前 韓国のソウルで
韓国人の父と日本人の母の間で生まれました
母の判断によって僕は韓国と日本
２つの国籍を持つ
二重国籍者として生まれました
そして生後６か月の赤ん坊の頃
僕は親の仕事の関係で初めて飛行機に乗せられ
中国まで飛んでいきました
そうやって 私たち家族の
中国での生活が始まりました
中国での生活は僕にとって
初めての海外生活とも言えますが
僕が初めて学んだ言葉も中国語であり
そして初めて受けた教育も 中国であり
そして中国の食べ物を食べながら
中国の子供たちと同じように
遊びながら育ちました
そうやって僕は
完全に中国の子供になっていました
しかし父は「これはまずい」
と思っていたようです
なぜなら僕は 中国語は
中国の子供のように話せましたが
自分の母国語である韓国語と日本語は
全然そうしゃべれなかったのです
「おまえのルーツを知るべきだ」
という父の言葉と共に
私たち家族は 韓国に戻ることになりました
そうやって僕は韓国で中学校に通い始めます
しかし 僕は何か違和感を
感じてしまったんです
韓国で生活が始まってから
僕は 体は韓国にいるが
心は長年暮らしてきた中国から
離れられませんでした
そして 何か属していないような
気分がしました
また 母が日本人だということで
僕は「多文化家庭子女」と指定されていました
それは当時 韓国が
年々外国から嫁入りする外国人が
特に東南アジアから増えてきて
見た目の違いや言葉の不自由さによって
差別をされることが問題視されていて
それを防ぐために
多文化家庭政策というのを行っていました
そのせいか 放課後
僕は担任の先生から呼ばれ
「家でちゃんと韓国語を学んでいるか？」とか
「学校でイジメられてないか？」と
長々と質問を受けまくりました
そして僕は思いました
「お父さん どうして？
ここって 僕の国なんじゃないの？」
しかし 何よりも大変だったのは勉強でした
韓国では中学校に入ったら
もう激しい競争 ―
学歴競争社会に入っていて
勉強がすごく厳しかったです
ちゃんと韓国で教育を
受けたことのなかった僕が
いきなり飛び込むのも
なかなか簡単なことではありませんでした
周りのクラスメイトたちも必死に
大学という目標に向けて走っていました
僕も何が何だかわからず
とにかく頑張って走っていました
そして ある日ふと思いました
僕 一体なんでこんな
頑張っているんだろう？
そして この走った先には
一体何があるんだろう？
答えがわからなくなった僕は
周りの大人たちにその問いをすると
このようなことを聞きました
「あなたは大きくなったら
立派な外交官になるから」
立派な弁護士になるから」
「あなたは大きくなったら
立派なお医者さんになるであろうから」
「今頑張って勉強して
良い大学に行きなさい」と
僕はそうやって周りの人たちが
「夢であるべき」と話している事柄に対して
どれ一つも 自分を
当てはめることができませんでした
[普通の韓国の学生]
よくよく考えると
僕は夢のためなんかより ―
別に夢のために
頑張っていけたわけではなく —
とにかく「普通じゃない」
と見られるのが怖くて
普通の韓国の学生に
頑張ってなろうとしていたのです
こんな頑張った先が 普通の韓国の学生に
なろうとしていただけだったのか
なにか虚しく思ってしまいました
その時僕は自分のもう１つのルーツである
日本に行ってみようじゃないか
と思い始めました
それまで僕は
日本で暮らしたことはありませんが
日本国籍があるということで
僕は 「帰国子女」という枠で
大学に入ることができました
僕は韓国の経験から
やっぱり普通の日本人に僕がなることも
できないよなと思いました
でも幸いなことに
僕と似たような
日本国籍を持っているが海外で育った ―
帰国子女という仲間がたくさんできたことで
僕は 「ああ 普通じゃなくてもいいんだな」
と思えるようになってきました
そして僕はある意味「国籍」という
しがらみからは少し自由になって
自分は自分だと思えるようになっていました
それ以来 僕は自己紹介をする時は
「僕は 中国で育った
日本と韓国のハーフです」とか
何人かを問われた時は
「僕は東アジア人です」と答えていました
そして その同時に僕はまた一方で
国とか国籍とかには関係なく
世界のために働く国際公務員のようになって
世のために働けばいいんじゃないか
という憧れの夢も実は膨らませていました
そうしたある日 僕にこれが届きました
「国籍選択届」というものです
この届は 僕みたいに
二重国籍を持っている人が
満22歳になる前までに
どちらかの国籍を選ばなければいけない
ということを意味していました
それで「結局あなたは何人になるの？」
この質問を国という存在からも
されるようになりました
ちょうどその頃 韓国は国籍法が変わって
二重国籍を認めるようになりましたが
韓国の兵役に行ってこないと
軍隊に行ってきてケジメをつけないと
韓国の国籍を放棄するのも
認めてくれないと言いました
そして日本では
日本で二重国籍は認めないと
その上に外国の軍隊など公的機関には
日本国籍を持っている以上は
行ってはいけないというのです
僕は２つの国の国籍を持つことで
２つの国の制度の狭間で
どうしようもできないような
状態に陥っていました
僕は混乱しました
なぜなら その時
どっちかの国籍を選ばないと
自分がやっと夢だと思っていた
国際公務員にもなれないってことを知りました
そしてどっちかを選べ
ということを追いせめられ
また落ち込みました
どっちにも属さない自分 ―
属せない自分は 結局
世界から受け入れられないんだなと
そして 国や周りや社会が
望む答えを出せない僕は
存在価値もない
厄介なやつなんではないかと
僕は たくさん悩んだ中
この悩みから また逃げたいとも思いました
なぜなら 寂しかったからです
そうです
僕の悩みは周りから
「結局あなたは何人なの？」と問われた時
その問に対して人たちが望む答えを
できなかったことなんです
周りが当たり前と思うことが
当たり前じゃなかった経験は寂しい経験でした
こんな悩みなんか人に言っても
わかってくれないでしょうと思ってしまったり
逃げたかった悩みですが
でも僕はこの悩みから絶対逃げない
と思うきっかけがありました
それは無国籍者たちとの出会いでした
無国籍者とは
国籍というステータスを持っていない
つまり どこの国からも
国民として認められていない
そのような状態にある人たちを意味します
その人たちの存在を僕は大学２年生の時
図書館で偶然手に取ったこの『無国籍』という
本を通じて知ることになりました
ぜひこの本の作者に会ってみたいなと思い
そう思っていた時にちょうど
大阪でシンポジウムが行われて
そこで僕はその作者に
会うことができたんです
その方はこの写真の左側に写っている ―
そして実は今日この場にも
ご来場いただいているララさんです
ララさんはご自身が
無国籍者だった経験を通じて
無国籍のストーリーテリングを行い
この問題を知らせていったり
無国籍という境遇にある人たちの
支援活動を行っていました
僕は ララさんとの出会いを通じて
「日本にもたくさんの無国籍者がいる」と
そして国籍という
ステータスがないことによって
海外渡航ができなかったり
あるいは結婚ができなかったり
あるいは この世の中に存在しない人として
扱われてしまったりする境遇の中にいる
人たちと出会うことができました
しかし そのように世の中から
否定されている中
僕が出会った無国籍の方々は
生き生きと自分の人生を歩んでいました
あるミャンマーの無国籍者は
大学生でしたが
同期が海外に修学旅行に行く時に
一緒に行けなかったり
大学の奨学金がもらえなかったり
たくさんの壁にぶち当たっていました
しかし 彼はこう言いました
「海外旅行に行けなくても僕は
人の何倍も国内旅行を楽しんでいる」とか
「奨学金がもらえなくても
自分が好きなアルバイトをやり続けて
勉強を続ける」と語っていました
なにか しみじみと
心の中に入ってきました
たとえ世の中が
存在を否定したからといっても
自分は自分を信じる
その姿を一生 僕は
忘れてはいけないなと思いました
たとえ周りが望む答えに応えられなくても
周りが望んでいるように
どこかの国や場所に根付かなくても
僕は自分自身の答えに
根付きたいと思い始めました
そして この悩みは必ずどこかでまた
分かち合える人たちがいるはずだから
そしてまた同じくどこかで
寂しい思いをしている人たちがいるはずだから
この悩みからは
絶対逃げたくないと思いました
そして この悩みをどんどん
また世界にぶつけていきたいとも思いました
大学３年生の頃
僕は 香港に留学をしていたのですが
ちょうどその時 中国政府に対して
香港では激しい民主化運動が勃発していました
僕の香港の友達も
毎日のように中心街に出て
座り込みをして
デモに参加していました
これは一体どのようなことが —
どのようなきっかけが
彼のそのような熱気のある行動に
導いているかが気になり
彼とご飯を食べながら訊いてみると
彼は僕に悩みを言ってくれました
彼はこう言いました
「自分が生まれ育った
この香港を大切に思う」
そして「親から与えられた
そして自分が享受してきたこの自由も
すごく大切に思う」
「でも何だか 今それが
失われようとしているんだ」と
「よく自分もわかっていないかもしれないけど
それが僕は怖いんだ」
「その気持ちを伝えていかないと
誰もわかってくれないんだ」と
おそらく
僕は彼と生まれ育った場所も違うので
こうやって彼に話を聞いていなかったら
彼が抱えていたその悩みもわからず
一生過ごしていただろうと思いました
世の中にたくさん
自分の知らない場所で
このように 悩みに必死に
向き合っている人たちがいるだろうなと思い
ぜひまずその人たちの存在を
知らなければいけないと
知りたいと思いました
僕は世界190か国以上から
およそ二千人の若き活動家たちが集まる
「ワンヤングワールド」というサミットに
参加できる機会がありました
そこでも 僕は自分の悩みを
ぶつけていきたいと思い
そしたらまた たくさんの
出会いにめぐり合いました
そこには北朝鮮から自由を求めて脱北したが
その過程で親を失い
そして家族とバラバラになり
それでも自由を追い求めて
続けている脱北者の少女がいました
そこには 南アフリカの小さな村で生まれ
恵まれてない環境で生まれたと
馬鹿にされ続けたが
それでも夢があれば何でも
成し遂げられることを証明するために
自分で学校を建てたり本を書いたりしながら
啓蒙活動を行っている ある青年がいました
そしてそこには 世界で最も人口の多い
無国籍民族とも言われる
クルド人出身でありながら
周りで 居場所を失ってしまった
シリア難民のために
支援活動を行っている友人ができました
それぞれ異なるバックグラウンドの中
異なる点も確かにたくさんありましたが
僕はその違いというよりかは
何かを分かち合える共通点に目が行きました
それはそれぞれ異なる悩みを抱いていて
その異なる悩みに向き合うことで
さらに自分たちのモチベーションに
なっているということです
僕も最初は 誰に言っても
わからないであろうという悩みでしたが
向き合っているうちに
分かち合える人たちができていきました
そしてその悩みに向き合っていることで
その人たちから「元気をもらった」
という声をいただきました
気づけばそれは僕のとっても大きな幸せ
そして生きがいになっていったのです
皆さまも一人一人
異なる悩みを抱えていると思います
しかし その異なる悩みがあるからこそ
そこから生まれる異なる答えがあって
その異なる答えがまた
みんなそれぞれ違う異なる人生を
描いていけるように
するのではないでしょうか？
そして僕はこれらの経験から
３つのことを教えてもらいました
まず自分の悩みに向き合うことで
自分の心の中にある答えに近づけること
そしてこの答えを信じてみることで
悩みは原動力になりうること
そして悩みを原動力に変えられた時
それはもう悩みではなく
僕は 「生きている意味」だと
思えるようになったということです
皆さんも一人一人
その悩みというものが
どんな小さな悩みでも
それは皆さんの心の中にある
大切な悩みだと僕は思います
どんな小さな悩みでも
それに向き合ってる時間が
周りから無駄だと言われても
僕はその悩みに向き合ってる姿を
ぜひ応援していきたいです
なのでぜひ 皆さまの話も
僕に聞かせてください
今日はご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）